[Musique]
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui dans science clic la
dilatation du temps le temps est une
notion essentielle pour décrire notre
monde
le temps qui passe permet de quantifier
l'évolution et le mouvement des objets à
première vue on pourrait penser que le
temps est absolue qu'ils passent
toujours au même rythme avec une même
horloge pour tout l'univers
mais au début du xxème siècle une
découverte vient bouleverser notre
compréhension
la relativité en relativité le temps
n'est plus absolu il est relatif chaque
objet porte son propre temps sa propre
horloge et deux horloges initialement
synchronisée en suivant des trajets
différents dans l'espace peuvent se
retrouver réprésenter un décalage en
l'expérience est réalisé à l'aide
d'horloges atomiques embarqué dans deux
avions
après un voyage autour de la terre en
sens opposé les deux horloges
initialement synchronisée présente
désormais un décalage le contenu du
premier avion horloge passagers et
autres objets semble avoir vieilli 320 9
secondes de moins que le contenu de
l'autre avion un décalage parfaitement
perceptible par ce type d'horloge très
précises comment expliquer ce phénomène
comment expliquer que l'une des deux
horloges et mesuré une durée plus courte
que l'autre
le temps s'est il dilate et sept-îles
écoulé plus lentement
pour comprendre ce phénomène
intuitivement il va être utile de
considérer une situation qui à première
vue n'a pas vraiment de rapport
on imagine simplement une prairie sur
laquelle une personne à avance tout
droit à un pas régulier en comptant ses
pas à mesure la distance quel parcours à
travers la prairie sur cette prairie se
trouvent deux arbres et à est orienté de
sorte qu'au 20e pas elle franchit les
deux arbres en même temps maintenant une
deuxième personne b avance elle aussi
tout droit au même rythme que à mais pas
dans la même direction
de son point de vue b ne passe pas les
deux arbres en même temps elle franchit
d'abord l'arbre de droite au 15e pas
puis l'arbre de gauche au 26e pas pourra
le passage des deux arbres et
simultanées mais pour b il se produit en
décalé l'ordre de passage dépend de la
direction dans laquelle on se déplace
imaginons que à observe les traces de
pas laissées par b de son point de vue à
ne perçoit pas la direction de cette
race elle observe uniquement qu'elle
semble plus rapprochée que les siennes
comme si bay avait marqué dès pas plus
court
de même pour b les traces laissées par
assemble contracter
en réalité a et b marche au même rythme
les traces sont identiquement espaces et
il est juste question de perspective car
l'orientation est différente pour finir
imaginons que a et b marche dans la même
direction mais cette fois ci la prairie
n'est pas plane le chemin de b passe par
une colline encore une fois pour à
l'ehpad e bay semble contracté comme
s'ils étaient plus courts et encore une
fois il est juste question de
perspective les pas de besson bien
régulier mais ils sont orientés
différemment
ils suivent la pente de la colline si
bien que pour as il semble plus court
pour résumer lorsque deux personnes
comparé leurs traces de pas elles
peuvent observer des pas plus court qui
semble contracter d'une part si les
directions sont différentes et d'autre
part si la surface est courbé
cette contraction n'est cependant qu'un
effet de perspective
en réalité les deux personnes marchent
toujours au même rythme
[Musique]
revenons à notre problème initial
d'après la relativité les objets dans
l'univers se déplace à travers une
surface qu'on appelle l'espace ton c'est
une surface assez complexe à quatre
dimensions et pour simplifier on peut
l'imaginer à deux dimensions comme la
prairie dans l'espace-temps tous les
objets se déplacent et au cours de leur
trajectoire
les horloges de chaque objet tourner le
temps qu'ils portent s'écoule à mesure
qu'ils avancent
le temps que porte un objet est donc
l'équivalent des traces de pas dans la
prairie
les seconds qui passe sur notre horloge
mesure la distance que l'on parcourt
dans l'espace temps il est très
important de comprendre que tous les
objets qu'il s'agisse d'un humain d'une
pomme d'une étoile ou d'un atom se
déplace toujours au même rythme en
l'intervalle d'une seconde
nous parcourons tous une même distance
environ 300 mille kilomètres dans
l'espace temps mais pas tous dans la
même direction
chaque observateur porte deux axes 1
qu'il appelle le temps dirigée selon sa
trajectoire au cours duquel s'écoule les
secondes et l'autre axe perpendiculaire
qui l'appelle l'espace un objet qui se
déplace dans la même direction que nous
nous semble immobile
l'objet est bien en mouvement dans
l'espace temps mais sur la ksk on
appelle espace il ne change pas de
position
al'inverse si l'objet avance dans une
direction différente de la nôtre
il nous semble en mouvement sa position
varie sur l'axé ce passe c'est ce qu'on
appelle la vitesse
la vitesse entre deux objets représente
simplement l'angle que forment leurs
trajectoires dans l'espace temps comme
dans la prairie
si l'on imagine deux événements qui se
produisent au même instant pour nous ces
deux événements peuvent se produire en
décalé pour quelqu'un d'autre qui
seraient orientés différemment
la simultanéité est relative
attention il ne s'agit pas d'une simple
illusion d'optique
mais bien d'une différence de
référentiels les deux observateurs ont
des définitions différentes de ce qu'ils
appellent le temps et l'espace leur axe
ne sont pas les mêmes d'où cette
différence de perception comme dans la
prairie
si on observe un objet qui se déplacent
par rapport à nous on perçoit son axe
temps selon une perspective différente
comme s'il s'écoule est un rythme
différent
en réalité les temps des deux objets
c'est cool tu au même rythme mais dans
des directions différentes
c'est cet effet qu'on appelle dilatation
du temps on comprend bien qu'il ne
s'agit pas réellement d'une dilatation
le rythme du temps n'a pas changé il est
simplement question de perspective
si l'on imagine deux jumeaux qui se
séparent l'un restant sur terre l'autre
effectuant un aller-retour à grande
vitesse dans l'espace les trajets
n'ayant pas la même longueur dans
l'espace temps alors réunion les deux
jumeaux n'auront plus le même âge
[Musique]
dans l'expérience des deux avions
l'explication est similaire
les deux avions se séparent parcours des
trajectoires différentes dans l'espace
temps il se trouve que l'une des deux
trajectoires et plus longue que l'autre
en terme de distance dans l'espace temps
les horloges non pas parcouru la même
distance et ne mesurent donc pas la même
durée enfin comme pour la prairie si
l'espace ton est courbé ce qui est le
cas autour d'un astre massif comme la
terre on va là aussi percevoir un effet
de dilatation du temps les seconds
semble passer à des rythmes différents
pour deux objets à des altitudes
différentes deux jumeaux qui se sépare
vivent chacun à des altitudes
différentes puis se rejoignent n'auront
pas parcouru la même distance dans
l'espace temps si bien que l'un des deux
aura vieilli davantage que l'autre dans
la situation extrême où la pente serait
verticale un objet s'y déplaçant
semblerait figé depuis l'extérieur
situation analogue à l'horizon d'un trou
noir
[Musique]
pour conclure l'analogie de la prairie
donne une bonne intuition géométrique de
ce qu'on appelle le temps en relativité
les objets se déplacent tous à travers
une surface l'espace temps et portent
chacun leur propre axe temps et espace
si bien qu'en étant orientés
différemment les durées et les distances
qu'il mesure sont différentes
l'analogie de la prairie présente
cependant des limites
elle n'est pas parfaitement équivalente
avec la relativité en particulier dans
la prairie les traces de pas nous semble
contracté alors qu'en relativité celle
inverse le temps d'un objet en mouvement
nous semble dilatées autre différence
dans la prairie il est possible de
revenir sur ses pas on peut faire demi
tour mais dans l'espace temps bien que
les objets puisse accélérer autant
qu'ils le souhaitent changer de
direction
leurs trajectoires sont restreintes à
l'intérieur d'un cône la géométrie
particulière de l'espace temps les
empêche de faire demi tour dans cette
géométrie un peu spécial le théorème de
pythagore n'est plus vrai cette
trajectoire est plus courte que celle ci
et il existe une sorte de vitesse limite
la vitesse de la lumière
on parle de géométrie lorraine sienne
[Musique]
bon